7,4 pour cent c'est le taux de chômage
chez les 55-64 ans en 2018
difficile pour eux à la proche de la
retraite de retrouver un emploi et ce
depuis des décennies et ça tombe des
gens de 50 ans ou de 55 ans qui ne
trouvent plus actuellement du travail
déjà dans les années 70 l'entreprise ne
favorise pas l'embauché de seniors qu'il
soit ouvriers employés ou cadres
le matin j'ai plus les annonces du
figaro du monde éventuellement j'ai créé
des entreprises c'est ce qu'on appelle
une candidature spontanée et puis
l'après midi et je peux avoir simplement
promener ce qui est désespérant
en 1980 le taux de chômage des 50 64 ans
et de 3,8 pour cent
je peux vous dire que c'est le
découragement le plus complet et ils
augmentent décennie après décennie pour
atteindre 6,9 pour cent en 2014
malgré tout le taux de chômage des
seniors est inférieure à la moyenne des
français et reste bien en-deça des
chiffres observés chez les 15 24 ans en
revanche le chômeurs seniors les souvent
pour une longue durée
dans 64% des cas en 2018
car il est confronté à la frilosité des
employeurs ils ont énormément de
préjugés par rapport aux salaires par
rapport à la technologie par rapport au
dynamisme qu'ils ont des préjugés par
rapport
je veux dire au fait que les seniors
sont peut-être moins malléable
complètement exclu non reconnus qui dit
chômage après 50 ans dit carrières
incomplètes et donc petites retraites en
2018 en moyenne les français partaient à
la retraite à 62 ans et huit mois pour
une pension de base de mil 57 euros
[Musique]